that's a really interesting question and
sadly the answer isn't simple the simple
answer is no but now I've got to explain
why I'm saying that the answer is no the
answer is that every process for cooling
either also introduces the possibility
that you can introduce some extra energy
into the system you see cooling means
taking energy out and heating means
putting energy in but in order to take
energy out then it turns out that you
open the door for energy to go in take
laser cooling laser cooling takes the
energy out by having an atom coming
along and then a photon hits the atom
and slows the atom down then that photon
has to go someplace and when that photon
is shot out by the atom the atom recoils
and more energy goes in so there's a
balance between the cooling the heating
and you can try to make that balance
work more and more in your favor but you
can never make it work a hundred percent
cooling and no heating so that's one of
the reasons why you don't expect to ever
get to absolute zero on the other hand
what does it mean to be at Absolute Zero
it means that all the thermal motion
stops well I can take one atom and I can
take as much energy out of it as
possible so that it's in what we would
call the ground state the lowest
possible state of energy is it absolute
zero not really because in order to be
at Absolute Zero I really have to have a
whole bundle of things I can't really
talk easily about the temperature of a
single object I should really talk about
whole ensemble and if I do that with a
whole bunch of atoms what's going to
happen is maybe if I'm lucky maybe
ninety nine percent of them are going to
be in the ground state and then one
percent isn't so it's not absolute zero
I can't come up with any procedure that
is going to say a hundred percent of
time this atom is going to end up in the
ground state and that's what I would
need to be able to claim that I'd really
gotten to absolute zero but on the other
hand I can get so close to absolute zero
that for many experiments it's basically
absolute
zero for all practical purposes but not
for all experiments and we're constantly
working on trying to make things colder
because for some experiments it really
matters that we're not quite there